excalibur jaguar de chevaux elles se
sont toutes mises sur leur 31 pour ce
week-end spécial
objectif du jour impressionné le jury
pour sa 7e édition le rétro bauges
distribuer 5 prix de la voiture la plus
extravagante à la rue hors norme en
passant par la plus populaire façon il
ya plein de jolies voitures donc office
de partout et on garde une option pour
le mans soit allié les cinq jurés
doivent élire leur goût de coeur et ce
n'est pas si simple
jean vocation d'origine au maximum cd c
est vraiment avec sa couleur d'origine
c'est le summum parmi les grandes stars
du jour
la cadillac de ville primée dans la
catégorie américaine mais c'est cette
excalibur felton 4 qui fera chavirer le
coeur du jury pour jean pierre et
christiane venu en tant que visiteur le
coup de coeur tient aussi de la
nostalgie
la ds leurs premières amours une petite
anecdote peut-être à nous raconter je me
réabonné gros des bêtises de jeunesse
aujourd'hui le rétro bourges c'est près
de 10000 visiteurs qui viennent voir
quelques 700 véhicules
mais il ya sept ans ce n'était pas sa
vocation la toute première année c'est
un projet d'étudiant on a créé ça parce
qu'on avait un projet tutoré affaires
l'iut de bourges et du coup on s'est dit
on aime bien les vieilles voitures on en
a pas mal avec les copains tous ces
débats tiens on va créer un
rassemblement de vieilles voitures
victime de son succès le festival a dû
refuser des exposants
il envisage de s'agrandir pour l'an
prochain